it's called surge testing but here in
pendle at least there is no surge of
people
this area is inside one of eight indian
variant hotspots
the same variant that some say is
driving a third wave
everybody in pendle i think knows
somebody who's died of corvid in the
last year who has suffered with corvid
please
go and get yourself tested and if god
forbid
you test positive we need to isolate we
need to adhere to what the rules are
whether we agree with them or not the
rules are there for a purpose
dominic cummings said this week boris
johnson had to be convinced
at the start of the pandemic to move to
plan b
a national lockdown and he credits
this man professor timothy gowers for
changing his
and the prime minister's mind and
probably
saving tens of thousands of lives
professor gowers what are the numbers
telling you
right now i think they're saying already
enough
to make me feel a bit anxious
because they seem to be multiplying by a
certain fraction
each day in other words growing
exponentially
professor gowers told me he's no fan of
lockdowns
but when needed interventions must be
made quickly
to be effective it's actually
counterproductive
to wait until you're really forced to
have a lockdown and then have the
lockdown that's the thing that i think
that's the mistake that's been made a
number of times and i really
hope that that particular mistake will
not be made again
in just under two months time wembley
will host
the euro 2021 final
there's a strong belief that it will be
at full capacity
today it's host to another of the
football calendar's main events
the playoff final with 10 000 supporters
in attendance i think they should do
more test events where you know you're
gradually increasing the capacity
rather than 10 000 today and then
potentially 90 000
in only weeks away i want to be back in
the stadiums we'll be back watching
bands
bring life back you know we have to pay
attention to what's happening with the
indian variant
i know everybody wants to go back to
normal but we can't drop our guard now
opening up the country will invariably
see a rise in infection rates
but the government insists our testing
and surveillance system
is working and vaccine cues like this
one in the borough of hounslow
another variant hotspot mean every day
even more of us are better protected
joshi sky news